now the chancellor Jeremy Hunt says it's
disappointing but not unexpected that
the UK's economy has contracted uh
household Finance expert Greg Marsh is
here to break it all down for us hi Greg
so an announcement this morning what
exactly did we learn yeah well what
we've had this morning is disappointing
September numbers meaning that as a
whole the third quarter of this year the
UK economy contracted got a bit smaller
how much smaller well not a lot to get a
sense for how much smaller you can see
that little glimpse of red there 0.2
percent over the quarter barely enough
to measure but enough and it might even
be such a small effect that that extra
bank holiday in September was enough to
account for that now where was it led it
was led by the manufacturing sector
where we've seen the biggest declines in
output but taken as a whole this matters
because if there's another contraction
next quarter we're in a recession and it
might be one that lasts a while
and why is this happening
well more than anything else it's
probably because of this consumer
sentiment Now consumer confidence in the
UK is particularly badly affected by
cost of living crisis Rising costs of
food Rising costs of fuel rising cost of
energy High interest rates and other
factors maybe even the political turmoil
that we've all endured over the last few
months you can see that versus the other
G7 countries it's at an historic low
level and the consequence of that at the
cash points and the checkout tills is
this while essential spending remains
robust that's of course a function of
the fact that the cost of everything's
gone up so everything's more expensive
about 10 more expensive things that
households can delay buying or
expenditure they can defer they are
deferring a very significant effect
there if there's a silver lining to this
data it's that where it comes to going
out to the pub and restaurants it looks
like that's held up okay maybe it will
continue to hold up okay publicans would
hope that that stands up particularly if
you know England and Wales do well in
Qatar over the next few weeks but
when it comes to the tills at the
supermarket it's a more mixed picture
because inflation's gone up you can see
this crocodile mouth here opening the
amount that we're spending say for
potatoes or eggs or anything else is
increased but the number of those things
that our money is buying the number we
can buy for every pound we spend is
decreasing and those are the Jaws that
are eating up consumer confidence and
consumer sentiment we're paying more but
we're getting less for our money
okay Greg if this is the first quarter
of recession
how long do we think it's going to last
do we have any idea
the bank of England think this could be
the start of a recession that might last
several years but how long it lasts
depends more than anything else on
interest rates
at their current level three percent
interest rates if this this downturn
could take us through until probably the
early part of 2024 that's the point that
that dotted Blue Line begins to turn
upwards and the economy starts growing
again
but if interest rates remain at the
level or go to the level that it's
widely forecast stable reach four or
five maybe even nearly six percent look
this recession could easily last eight
quarters or longer and that's
unfortunately the bad news that
everyone's factoring in to 2023. okay
Greg thank you so much